За даними власного розслідування Фейсбук,
протягом останнього півтора року фейкові акаунти
витратили в США близько 100 тисяч доларів
на банерну рекламу і просування постів
політичного характеру.
При цьому всі «фейки» були пов'язані між собою
і «ймовірно, керувалися з Росії».
Фейсбук підкреслює: в цій рекламі
практично не згадувалися конкретні кандидати і вибори.
Однак піднімалися гострі для американського суспільства питання:
іммігранти, володіння зброєю,
расові питання, права ЛГБТ,
використовувалися такі слова
як "патріот" і "біженці".
Чи є це доказом втручання Росії у вибори в США?
У Вашингтоні, де триває розслідування впливу Москви на вибори,
уважно вивчають цю інформацію.
Однак німецькі експерти вважають:
поспішати з висновками зарано. Насамперед підозри викликає
сума - 100 тисяч доларів. Для порівняння -
чистий прибуток самого Фейсбук, який заробляє в основному на рекламі,
склав минулоріч понад десять мільярдів доларів.
Однак ітися може про «обкатку» технологій
з маніпуляції громадською думкою.
100 тисяч доларів - зовсім невелика сума.
Для порівняння, Дональд Трамп витратив
30 мільйонів доларів на онлайн-рекламу під час передвиборної кампанії.
Радше йдеться не про пряме втручання,
а про тестування технології.
Якщо такі новини показувати певній цільовій групі,
то можна провести доволі надійний експеримент,
результати якого дадуть можливість
розробити нові стратегії щодо маніпуляцій.
Чи можна застосувати цю технологію в інших країнах?
Трохи більше ніж через два тижні
відбудуться вибори в німецький Бундестаг.
фейкові новини та інші інструменти пропаганди
були помічені і в Німеччині. Про це попереджає і Фейсбук.
Нині компанія працює над тим,
щоб мінімізувати вплив фейкових акаунтів.
Цього року ми покращили наші технології з виявлення
фальшивих акаунтів і вжили низку заходів,
би зменшити обсяг дезінформації та "фейкових новин".
За останні кілька місяців ми також видалили
фальшиві акаунти у Франції, Німеччині та інших країнах.
А ті, хто регулярно поширював фейкові новини,
більше не зможуть розміщувати рекламу на Facebook.
Після заяви Фейсбук про схожі технології
заявили і в офіційному Євросоюзі.
Так, оперативна робоча група зі стратегічних комунікацій,
створена для протидії дезінформації з боку Росії,
написала у своєму твіттері: «саме такі методи
ми спостерігаємо в Європі впродовж останніх років».